force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui la
turquie n'est plus un partenaire dans
cette région la turquie est un allié de
l'otan mais un allié de l'otan qui a eu
des pratiques inacceptables sur les
côtes libyennes à l'égard du courbet qui
opérait donc sur sur ses côtes
ce commandement otan la turquie a signé
des accords inacceptables avec le
gouvernement d'entente nationale libyen
néant les droits légitimes de la grèce
la turquie à des pratiques de forage en
zone chypriote en zone économique
exclusive qui sont aujourd'hui
inacceptables et multiplie les
provocations dans des termes d'ailleurs
qui ne sont pas dignes d'un grand état
le peuple turc est un grand peuple et
ils méritent autre chose et je pense jeu
quand je parle d'une pax méditerranée à
elle doit aller avec la capacité à
trouver un modus vivendi avec la turquie
mais nous devons nous européens être
clair et ferme avec non pas la turquie
comme nation comme peuple mais avec le
gouvernement du président erdogan qui
aujourd'hui à des comportements
inadmissibles et je n'ai cité qu'une
partie j'ai évidemment pas parler des
actes unilatéraux et des provocations de
cet été à l'égard de la grèce nos lignes
rouges sont simples le respect de la
souveraineté de tout état membre
européen le respect du droit
international
la condamnation de tous les actes
unilatéraux
notre volonté c'est d'éviter toute
escalade mais éviter l' escalade ne doit
pas signifier la passivité ou
l'acceptation les lignes rouges sont
celles que je viens d'évoquer
l'objectif c'est une concorde il
appartient à la turquie aujourd'hui de
clarifier ses intentions
et donc ce que je souhaite c'est que cet
après midi nous les sept européens
puissions dégager des lignes de force
sur nos lignes rouges
ce que nous souhaitons faire pour ré
engager un dialogue avec la turquie
de manière réaliste c'est à dire ce que
nous sommes prêts à faire et ce que nous
demandons
en face de cela mais avec des pré
conditions sur lesquelles nous serons
intraitables et qui ne sont pas
conditionnel c'est celle que je viens
d'évoquer
et je souhaite ensuite que au niveau
européen nous puissions avoir la même
clarté
l'europe doit avoir une voix plus unie
et plus clair la france a une position
ces derniers mois constante non pas une
position de l' escalade beaucoup ont
voulu nous renvoyer dos à dos avec la
turquie la france n'a jamais conduit
quelque acte unilatéral que ce soit sur
les eaux territoriales ou les zones
économiques exclusives de quelque état
que ce soit nous avons simplement
marquer notre soutien à des états
membres de l'union européenne
lorsque des actes unilatéraux de
provocation était conduit par la turquie
c'est très différent
nous avons simplement dit il ya des
lignes rouges